hey guys I just want to quickly talk
about how to use vitamin k2 first of all
what is it it's a recently discovered
vitamin they used to talk about vitamin
you know k1 alot which is actually helps
you clot but k2 is a completely
different part of that vitamin k complex
and vitamin k2 is vital in the
transportation of calcium from the wrong
place to the right place so a lot of
people have soft tissue calcium buildup
because naturally they're missing this
vitamin and so what happens they get
clogging of the arteries where they get
plaquing they have a tartar on the teeth
cataracts in arthritis and bursitis in
tendinitis but the net leads to high
blood pressure and stroke and all sorts
of things because the calcium starts
building up and as you see when people
get older they become really really
stiff that's the calcium building up
because they're missing this this comes
from naturally fat like grass-fed animal
products that's where you get this but
what do they they've been telling us to
avoid over the last 50 years fat that's
the worst thing to do so they want to
tell you to avoid cholesterol foods
because they don't want you to heart
attack when in fact this is in
cholesterol foods to help clean out the
calcium plaquing so the cholesterol
plaquing is really just these long-term
effects of having problems in the
arteries which you should watch other
videos if you want to get the full scoop
on that but the point is this is much
more important to help the
cardiovascular system and bone health
because it will take the calcium and
drive it right into that bone and make
it nice and solid and I always recommend
taking this with vitamin d3 so they work
together and if it's a if you have a
major problem take four of these and
four of vitamin d3 in the I think the d3
would be roughly about
10,000 IU's per pill and this is a
hundred micrograms so basically I have
these in the right combination so they
work together so you take a one-to-one
ratio if it's a major problem take four
and four in the morning if it's a minor
problem you're just maintaining it take
one of each okay now why do you take it
in the morning because the stomach is
mostly acidic in this in the morning and
it's it's the best to digest protein and
fats in the morning not the right before
you go to bed of course so go ahead and
take it and I recommend taking this with
some fat maybe a little butter or even
just with your eggs for breakfast so I
like to take it for breakfast
and then you can basically find that
it'll actually be absorbed into the
whole day you don't need to spread it
out through the day okay so four and
four or one and one they're in the right
ratios vitamin k2 in d3 for the
transportation of calcium and a lot of
other benefits that you run into okay so
there's no actual problem taking this on
the far side effects but there is a
point if you have a gall bladder problem
these are fat vitamins these are fat
soluble vitamins so if you have a
gallbladder bloating constipation don't
have a gallbladder then you need to add
gall bladder formula to this because
this will help you digest these too okay
so that's the only catch-22 with taking
this is because you might not be able to
absorb these fat soluble vitamins
because you don't have enough bile B il
e from your gall bladder okay so that's
the other point with this but that's how
you would take it and I hope that gave
you kind of a little bit of a summary of
of what you're going for